[Musique]
un petit peu comme celle-ci mais qui
descend
plus bas
[Musique]
comme jamais fini propre en parler ou
qu'une de ses langues en parler au
quotidien aucune
c'est plus des langues à approcher du
grec ancien où on peut faire de la
traduction ça peut s'étudier en détail
donc on est un petit peu universitaire
mais
généralement il faut une étude assez
poussée pour rentrer dans les langues de
Tolkien là où ce qu'on fait nous
l'atelier calligraphie s'adresse
vraiment à n'importe qui compris des
gens sans connaissance préalable en
linguistique
[Musique]
ça dure deux heures on va apprendre à
tracer les caractères elfiques qu'on
appelle les tenguares et en deuxième
partie enfin ensuite on va apprendre à
transcrire c'est à dire passer de
l'alphabet latin qu'on utilise tous les
jours à l'alphabet elfique notamment
pour écrire des prénoms
[Musique]
moi je suis une très grande fan de
Tolkien je m'étais un peu renseignée sur
l'écriture la calligraphie la
prononciation des langues sauf que toute
seule dans sa chambre c'est pas très
facile donc moi je voulais absolument
participer et c'était vraiment génial
c'était très bien présenté et puis c'est
accessible à tout le monde et c'est très
agréable c'est très joli à écrire c'est
vraiment satisfaisant
[Musique]
donc 30/24 et France 24 écrit au-dessus